I find writing the hardest part and I
procrastinate a lot and it's really hard
to be disciplined I really like using
final draft because as soon as you start
working at final draft it looks like a
script so it's really exciting and then
makes you want to keep going and I think
once you kind of get excited about it
then I would get excited to go back to
it and get kind of obsessed with it and
I remember I think my dad told me about
always leave when um when it's a part
that you like so that you're excited to
come back to it don't like exhaust the
good parts and leave it apart when it's
going well leave at that point so that
you're looking forward to coming back to
it which I thought was a good advice but
but I found writing hard and the hardest
part is of course you think it's dumb I
think don't don't read it too much when
you're writing it just keep going
forward because if you start reading it
then you just think it's awful and you
don't want to continue tried being a
writer but
I hate what I write so I I try to just
um not look back and keep going forward
until you're done and then then look
through it does it get easier no
yes
it gets easier